hey everybody welcome to some Mario
Odyssey gameplay I'm Troy Barska dares
hello so we played this game I had a
little razzle III when I was lucky
enough to get in there and we played it
at the Nintendo head office a few weeks
ago now we managed to complete a quest
but there's just so much more to talk
about this game yeah I mean what what I
made watch hands out of your head is it
just the 20 minutes yes I played a
little bit III and then a little bit the
other week but it was the same time at
both times so I played this level new
Don City and also the sand Kingdom as
well so I've played them both quite
extensively now and it's looking pretty
good I'm actually incredibly excited by
it
but before zelda came out i was not
known for being a massive Nintendo fan
but the switch has kind of turned this
completely around for me but we see
major major major pauline military mega
pauline the Questor forgive you i loved
it i love like the way it's Simlish
english illegit have yeah yeah yeah the
the quest that she gives you is she
wants a band for the festival so you
have to explore new dog city to get a
band yeah for members the band it kind
of feels like this quest was designed to
make you explore a little bit yeah
definitely we just find like really
that's just a great way of getting you
out into the city right definitely and
it feels like every corner of the world
is just filled with secrets yeah like
there's just so much to discover in a
way that although I loved Super Mario 3d
World
oh nice although I loved Super Mario 3d
World because they were linear levels it
wasn't like you could really explore
that much yeah
whereas this because each world is
essentially a mini open-world you can go
anywhere any way you want within that
and they have really packed it for
secrets see I've left this in here
because the main draw is obviously
musicians show it where they are but I
find that there's this aspect of like
platforming it's kind of two and a half
D right like that the camera has changed
to a sort of 2d perspective so it looks
like classic Mario but
control of a 3d game there were moments
explore a new dog see and some of the
platforming areas were actually kind of
struggled with like landing my jumps and
stuff
oh really sure why like I've never
really had that problem with a Mario
game in the past I've not had it maybe
you're just rushing games I might be
just rubbish the game is if it's just me
then it's I'm a genuinely be bad yeah
but um yeah it's kind of interesting to
have these levels within levels then why
the sonic wings there I mean yeah there
was there's a there's a part of the
other level that we played San Kingdom
where it goes into 2d but it also goes
into sort of like retro 8-bit yeah that
was one of the ones where like they they
actually put you against the wall like
80 right like that there was a level
like that in new dog city as well oh
really
yeah there was it was it was just like
to collect musical notes and rows near
the place where you can buy a tuxedo
right see that's amazing to me because
like I've played new donkey city I think
for I mean so it's quite although it is
an open-world it's quite a small one you
can and you can do the main quest of
this world in like five minutes
ten minutes max and I've played this
level like three times though so I've
played it for like half an hour yes and
I hadn't seen that
yeah you just talking it was just a very
nondescript building that like I was
walking past and I was like wait can I
actually go yeah there it turned out you
kids send off the fire singer [ __ ] why
why save us if we need it like there
that was just like a nondescript alley
but there was a was an open open doorway
in there yeah I am still kind of weirded
out and I don't think I'm alone in this
seeing Mario next to like human humans
yeah yeah I was just about to mention
that because like Mario is like Nintendo
said Mario is human yeah and he's next
to humans and they look completely
different and his proper weirding me out
like it's it's not even that there's
like a high discrepancy or something
like that Mario looks like he's made of
different stuff yeah he looks like a
cartoon doesn't yeah let you know when
like when you're in when you play Crash
Bandicoot you get squashed by a block he
goes until yank egg mode
it's like he's halfway to that I knees
in a tuxedo no yeah definitely I mean
but I should say although I think it is
really weird and I'm not of the levels
that they've shown off so this and the
San Kingdom and there's the dinosaur one
as well
and there's like a weird moon Kingdom as
well this is probably the one that
weirds me out the most because it is
trying to be sort of semi realistic and
Mario's in there and obviously not
realistic but I should say that although
it kind of weirds me out I don't think
it's especially a negative nug it's a
bit odd but is at the same time cool why
not
it's cool to see Mario in that setting
right and I keep comparing it to you
know that Simpsons episode where Homer
goes out into the real world he's still
sort of like 3d and weird and cartoony
but everyone else is like live-action
it's kind of like that it's weird but is
at the same time cool to see it in a
different setting yeah absolutely well
the reason I climbed up building then it
was I was trying to find the last
musician right and they try and trick
you by saying that there's music coming
from the ceiling writing in the roof so
I went out there at this point I noticed
see it found the one magician I haven't
so I turned to you in the event be like
Oscar bloody musician yeah that's a bit
that's the thing there is so much to
sort of discover and explore on and I'm
pleased today's the case because when I
when they first revealed Super Mario
Odyssey in the Nintendo switch
livestream if n I wasn't that keen on it
because I think from memory they only
showed off this world and maybe one
other yeah and I was like I don't know
it looks kind of odd and I'm not too
keen but then when I actually sat down
and played it and the more they showed
off you realise that it's actually got
so much variety in the same way Super
Mario 3d World had like yeah had so many
ideas and it would just throw away ideas
that other games would build whole games
around it and throw them away in one
level but I'm I'm super excited to learn
learn more about Mario like I've like I
said I've not been exactly the biggest
Mario fan but seeing it in this new
saying and all the new stuff I do with
it I'm super excited we've got the the
band back together now so we need to do
excited Oscar very excited I'm really
looking forward to actually also well
for all your Super Mario Odyssey news
reviews gameplay all that good stuff
stay tuned to game spoke on
you